You ever notice how the word
fascist is just everywhere these
days?
It gets slapped on political
opponents, on new laws, even on
entire countries.
But what does it actually mean?
Well, it turns out that really
depends on who you ask.
So how did we get here?
How did one of the most loaded
words of the 20th century just
break apart to the point where
we can't even agree on what
we're fighting about anymore?
To get our heads around this,
we've got to go back in time a
bit.
The author of our source
material?
He takes us back to his college
days, a time when fascism had a
pretty clear, settled definition
in political science.
It wasn't just a random insult
you threw around.
It was a specific thing, a
historical system you could
point to in a textbook.
So what was that original
definition?
All right, let's start right
there with that original
meaning, the one that was taught
in universities for decades.
This is our baseline.
You know, we need to understand
this before we can figure out
how everything got so tangled
up.
OK, the keyword here, the one
that would have been underlined
in your old textbook, was
corporatism.
This was the economic engine of
historical fascism.
Now, it's not about big
corporations like we think of
today.
The idea was that society is
like a single body, a corpus.
In this system, private
businesses weren't shut down.
Nope.
But they were forced to serve
the goals of the state.
So your factory, it was yours on
paper, but it's real boss was
the nation.
And this is how fascism sold
itself as a kind of third way,
something different from both
capitalism and communism.
See, communism says the state
owns everything, right?
The factories, the farms, the
whole shebang.
Fascism said, Nah, you can keep
your company, but it has to work
for national glory.
It keeps the outer shell of
capitalism, but totally hollows
it out, swapping the profit
motive for the state's big
agenda.
That distinction is absolutely
crucial.
So if the definition was once
that clear, what on earth
happened?
Well, over the last few decades,
that single academic term just
cracked right down the middle,
leaving us with two completely
contradictory definitions that
most people use today.
And boom, here it is.
This slide lays out the entire
communication breakdown.
On one side you've got what the
author calls the Normie view.
For them, fascism is simple.
It's Hitler, it's Nazis and anti
fascism.
That's the GIS who stormed the
beaches of Normandy.
But on the other side you have
the activist view.
And here fascism isn't some
historical bad guy.
It's the very structure of our
society.
Borders, flags, tradition.
And just look at the disconnect.
The symbols of anti fascism for
one group are the literal
symbols of fascism for the
other.
For the normie.
This whole idea is just baked
into the American identity.
It's in the stories our
grandparents told.
It's in all those old war
movies.
During the Cold War, America saw
itself as the world's number one
anti fascist nation.
So for this group, calling
America itself fascist just
doesn't compute.
It's a total contradiction.
But for the activist, that same
history is actually the problem.
They don't see fascism in goose
stepping soldiers, they see it
in systems of power they believe
are fundamentally oppressive.
So in this world view, being an
anti fascist isn't about
defending America, it's about
dismantling its traditional
structures from the inside out.
Now, these two views didn't just
pop up out of nowhere, right?
They each have their own unique
histories, their own
intellectual family trees, and
if we want to understand why
they're so opposed, we have to
understand where they came from.
You can think of the normie
perspective as getting a series
of firmware updates over the
years.
After fascism was defeated in
45, the main enemy for the next
50 years was communism.
Then after 911 it became
Islamist terrorism.
Each update reinforced this core
idea that America is the good
guy, the defender against
foreign evil ideologies.
The activist lineage though,
it's drawing from a completely
different library.
Its intellectual roots aren't
really in the fight against
Hitler.
They're an anti colonial
theories and Maoist thought
which saw Western nations
themselves as the oppressive
occupiers.
So for them, the real fight
isn't against some enemy
overseas, it's against the
status quo right here at home.
And this quote from the source
material just hits the nail on
the head.
It perfectly captures this
tragic disconnect.
You have two groups, both
looking at the exact same
American flag, and one sees a
symbol of liberation while the
other sees a symbol of
oppression.
They are operating in two
completely separate moral
universes.
OK, so here's the crucial point.
This isn't just some dusty
academic debate over
definitions.
This war over a word has massive
real world consequences for
whether we can even function as
a country.
The number one consequence is a
total breakdown in
communication.
When one side screams we have to
fight fascism and they mean
things like borders and
tradition, and the other side
hears we have to fight actual
Nazis, well there's no common
ground.
There's no conversation to be
had.
We're just shouting at each
other in different languages.
And what fuels this breakdown is
a deep sense of hypocrisy on
both sides.
The author points to what they
call a NIMBY paradox.
Not in my backyard.
They use this example.
California is a state that talks
a big game about inclusion, but
it's black population is only
7%, which is actually one of the
lower rates in the US.
And it's that perceived gap
between what people say and what
they do that just deepens the
distrust and makes any kind of
real dialogue feel impossible.
The author uses this great
metaphor.
Think of the word fascism like
an old skateboard.
It used to be a specific thing,
right?
Built for a specific purpose.
But now it's been totally
repurposed.
It's been emptied of its
original meaning, corporatism,
and it's been filled up with a
bunch of new ideas.
And now it's just used as a
weapon in a totally different
fight.
And here is the ultimate mind
bending irony of it all.
Both sides genuinely see
themselves as patriots on a holy
crusade.
One group truly believes they're
saving America from a kind of
rising Maoist style communism.
The other group truly believes
they're saving America from a
rising Nazi style fascism.
Both of them think they're the
real anti fascists.
Both think they're the true
defenders of democracy.
And their definitions are
completely, totally
irreconcilable.
And that leaves us with a
really, really unsettling
question.
Words.
They're the glue that holds a
society together.
They let us debate, compromise,
build something shared.
But when a word as powerful and
as important as fascism loses
all its shared meaning, what
happens to the glue?
What's left to hold Anything
together?